よろしくお願いします
今日は最後のテーマで
現代社会に仏教というものは通用しますか？というテーマで
聞く限りにはなかなか通用しないような感じもしますからね
やっぱり考えた方がいいんです
なんかすごい難しそうな話ばっかりして
現代人に通用するわけじゃないというふうに思うかもしれません
で それ難しいというならば
私はちょっと文句言いたいんですよ
じゃあ現代人は昔より随分自分たちが知識的に発達しているんだ
進んでいるんだと威張ってるんじゃないんですかね
それだったら何で難しいことをやるのは悪いんですかね
ただ 何か拝んだり 助けてくれ
助けてくれというぐらいの宗教だったら
原始時代ではいいんだけど
とことんチャレンジして
知識で当たってみて 本当に本当かないかと試してみなくちゃいけない
ちょっと手強い宗教は現代人にもっと適して合ってるんではないかと私は思ってるんですね
ですから 現代あっちこっち
まあそんなまあまあ修行やらいろいろ難しい話やらいろんなものあるんだから
仏教なんかはちょっと今は合わないよと
いう人々にはだいたいこういう文句を言いたいんですよ
じゃああなた方は昔 原始時代の人々みたいに
もう単なるバカの集まりですかと
それだったらまあ別に仏教なんか分かりにくいとか言っても構いません
なぜならば 昔は例えば洪水が出てきて
作物全部消えてしまったと
そうするといきなりああ
どうしようか どうやら神様の罰が当たったのではないかと思って
一生懸命拝んだり 儀礼やったり
たまに生贄までして神様の機嫌を取ろうとすると
で 仏教ではそうじゃなくて
物事に因果法則あるんだと
いろいろ原因によっていろいろ結果が出てくるんだ
そこで自分で何かからくりできる原因があるならば
それなりに人生を幸福にすることはできるんだと
そこでそこを間違ったら不幸になってしまうんだというふうな教えは仏教であって
それ難しいというならば
わかりにくいというならば
人間の考え方はもしかすると発達していないかもしれませんね
ですから そういうことでもないんだからね
我々は昔よりは随分考え方が優れて発達しているんだから
今こそ仏教のような宗教は社会に
現代人に合うはずなんです
で 私の個人的な考え方でいなれば
今は時代だと 仏教なんか勉強する時代は今ではないかと
ですから 古い人間には本当に頭を下げなくちゃいけないんですよ
あまり科学もなかったのに
いろいろそれなのに もう世の中のことも知らなかったのに
一生懸命この教えを純粋に今まで守ってきたんだから
今我々の知識で当たってみると
かなりいろいろ大変な真理を発見することはできるし
それはできるように 今までその仏教というものはもうぐちゃぐちゃいろいろ変化しないでずっと伝わってきたんですね
そこである社会では あるところでは
一般人に仏教は理解できない場合は理解できるように
ちょっといろんな工夫しちゃうんですね
それはある面でいいかもしれませんだけど
ある面で仏教は堕落しちゃうんですね
なぜならば 仏教っていうのは変化しない真理ですから
いつ言ったっても同じことだから
それはその時代の人々の考え方に合わせちゃうと
その人々は次に伝えるのはあの変な考え方なんですね
そうするとそれは古臭くなってしまうんですよ
一つの例を申し上げます
で 仏教ではこの慈悲の心というものを教えたんですね
この慈悲の心というのは
言葉だけ聞いたら慈悲ですかというふうに思いますけど
その中に深い真理的なこと入ってるんですね
慈悲というのは この自分の心のエネルギーと他人の心のエネルギーっていうのは
うまくスムーズに調和して
逆らうことなく スムーズにこの同じ方向へ流れるようにすることなんですね
例えば人が１万人いても
みんな同じ方向へスムーズに流れると
何も混雑なく生きれるんですね
そこで人が100人いて
一人はこっち来るは 一人はこっちから来るは
あっちからと そうすると
ごちゃごちゃになっちゃって動けなくなっちゃうんですね
人の100人集まりでも大変混乱状態にすることはできるし
あるお互いに邪魔しないで流れるならば 1
万人がいたっても何の問題なく人間が動いていることはできるんですね
同じく我々の心のエネルギーっていうのは
心の波動というのは 他の生命の波動とぶつかって混乱させちゃってやっちゃうと
なかなか自分には生きづらいんですよ
たまにいるんですね 一人の部屋で二人でいることもすごくややこしくて居づらいとという人々がいるんですよ
また 他の人はいっぱい人がいないと何か寂しくてしょうがないと
人が入ればいるほど楽しくてしょうがないと
例えば東京だったら嫌ですよという人がいるんですね
あまりにも人がいていていていて
もう人混みばっかしで嫌ですよという人もいて
まあ東京は面白くて もう田舎には戻りたくないという人もまたいるんですね
で どういうことかというと
このいっぱい人がいるのを見ると
この自分の心の波動が嫌なもう逆らっちゃうんですね
自分だけに自由自在に生きていきたいというわがままなみたいな感じがあって
この万人電車になんか乗るのは嫌がってしまっちゃうし
で そんなことじゃなくて
まあ自分に足ぐらいでも入る場所があったら
ざっと入って何のことなく立ってる人にとっては別に人がいくらいたっても構いませんし
そこで慈悲というのは
ことお釈迦様はそういうふうな
この心の基本的な波動だよと
いわゆる生命の幸福で
生命が一緒に生きるためには慈悲は必要ですよと
我々には生命を殺すことはできないんです
輪廻から考えなくちゃいけない
人を殺すことはできますけど
我々は人は殺しちゃっても
その人はまた他の生命として生まれ変わっちゃう
また死んじゃって また生まれ変わっちゃうというと
その方程式から見ると
生命はいつでも同じくいるんですよ
我々のおじいちゃんおばあちゃん死んじゃって
また幽霊になって戻ってくるんだから
まあ死んだわけにはならないと
で 形が変わって また他の形で生きているというならば
生命を殺して生命排除して他の生命を嫌だ出ていけということでは生きていられない
ですから どうですかとこんにちはという感じで
手をつなげて仲良くやろうではないかという感じで生きていかなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから うちで飼っている猫が猫にも人間らしく生活しろと
ちゃんとトイレに行って用を足しなさいとかねと言ったっても意味がない
猫は猫で猫らしくいてください
我々は人間で人間らしくいますよと言うと
お互いにすごく仲良く生活することができるんですね
そういうふうに この生命のエネルギーの波動に逆らうなと逆らう代わりに
お互いの波動にうまくスムーズに合わせて
相手の波動に自分は乗り移ってもらうことではなくて
このぴったし合うように合わせて生活する
その真理は慈悲というふうに教えたんですね
それを実践するために
とにかく頭に言い返しなさいと
生きとし生けるものは幸福でありますように
幸せでありますようにと
私の人生のモットーは
全ての生命は幸福であってほしいというモットーだよと
そういうふうに生きてくださいと
そうすると 心から人と逆らいたがる気持ちが消えていっちゃう
消えていっちゃうと素晴らしく
何の一人も敵がなくて
動物でも何でももう誰でも自分にもう逆らうことなく
すごく美しく生きてられるんですよ
誰が見たっても楽しくしょうがない
鳥が枝の上で立って座って鳴いている時はもう楽しすぎてしょうがない
この鳥の幸福も自分に伝わってくる
で 他の人が悲しくて泣いてると
あ やっぱりこの人悲しんでるんだとか
そこを特に同調して あ
なるほど それ理解できるな
やっぱりなんとかうまくいってほしいとか思う気持ちが出てくる
そうすると生命がいればいるほど人生は幸福になる
でも その心の論理を 例えば遠い昔
この波動という概念さえなかったし
こんな昔の人々はそんなことをわかっているわけでもないし
そこでどんどんみんなにわかるようにいろいろ工夫しちゃうんですね
この慈悲の文句を一回だけ唱えても
偉大なる徳があるんだと
もうどんな問題も解決できるんだと
病気は治りますと 体は美しくなるんだと
嘘を言ってるわけじゃないんです
人間にわかりやすく言うんですよ
いわゆるわかりやすく
人生はうまく運べますよという意味なんですけど
病気にはなりませんと
家族はみんな仲良くしましょうと
家は火事になりませんと
ですから 一回だけでも唱えても
それぐらい徳ありますよって言うんですよ
それは当時の人にわかりやすくするためにちょっとした解釈であって
それだけ取っちゃうと
慈悲の文句っていうのはなんかすごい偉大なる呪文みたいな力を持ってるんではないかと勘違いするんです
それで一回二回唱えて
なんかその なんていうか
神秘的なこの超能力みたいなエネルギーは自分に入ってくるんだと待ってるんです
それは釈尊の教えとはちょっと違うんですよ
一回だけちょっと解釈してやってもいいんだけど
この解釈から解釈しちゃうともうダメなんです
そこでどんどんそれこの解釈広げて広げていって
こうなったんですね 私は生きとし生けるものの幸福を願うと
私に幸福してくれる誰かがいるんじゃないかと
だから普通に見たっても
我々の幸福は他の人からいただくものでしょ
家庭の幸福はお母さんお父さんから頂いているし
まあみんな我々は社会から幸福を頂いて楽しく生活してるんだから
これは頂くもんだと ですから
慈悲の心を持ってると
もう誰かからこれを頂くんだと
頂くならば 人間ではなくて
やっぱり神様の方がもっと立派なんですね
ですから 慈悲の心を持ってる人に
神様から何か頂くんではないか
仏様から何かご褒美もらうんではないかと
またすごい勘違いする
それさらに果たして この慈悲そのものを象徴的にとって人格化する
人格化すると 慈悲の神が現れちゃうんですね
慈悲そのものの神が現れると
それは現代皆様が知ってる観音さんなんです
とにかく人々を助けてあげたいとずっと待っているんだと
そうすると人間どうなったかというと
慈悲は忘れて観音様お願いします
観音様お願いしますというようになってしまったんですね
じゃあもともとおっしゃったあのすごい偉大なる真理はどこへ行ったんですか？消えてしまったんですね
心の波動 生命と生命の心がぶつかっちゃったら大変混乱するんだと
不幸になるんだと 生きづらくなるんだと
ですから我々は心のつなぎで素晴らしく生きてるんだと
という真理が消えちゃったんですね
観音様はどうか私の子供を助けてください
病気治してくださいと言われるようになったんですね
それから観音さんはまたすごい変身する
読違い観音やら馬頭観音
ああだこうだとか まあ人の希望通りにいろいろ変身してしまう
それは全部人間が作ったもので
決してそういうものはいるわけじゃないんですよ
だから みんな仏教は信じる人は信じるし
疑う人は疑っちゃうし
だから現代人から見れば
それはおかしいんじゃないかと思った方がいいかもしれません
でも釈尊の教えはそうじゃなくて
徹底的に厳密に真理だけ語っている
それ変化しちゃったら
すぐ道から外れてしまっちゃうんですね
一回だけいいんですよ
わかりやすくするために
その一回の解釈は解釈
そこで止まっていただいて
もう二度と解釈から解釈しないことなんです
だから私も今解釈しているんです
私の解釈を聞いて それにそれからまた解釈しちゃうと
お釈迦様の言葉から離れてしまうんです
もし私の解釈をしてわかったならば
皆様お釈迦様の教えからまた自分の解釈をするしか他の方法はないんです
そうすると解釈はそんなに変化しないんです
そういうことで ただ慈悲のことを見ても
今我々には心のことわかるでしょうに
いくらか いろんな研究も発達しているし
人の心のエネルギーってどういうものかとわかっているし
心のエネルギーはどのように体に影響を与えるかと
それもわかっているし
例えば嫌な人がいると
その嫌な人にはみんなの人生を無茶苦茶にすることできるでしょうに
会社にしたっても うちにしても
学校にしたっても 一人がもうとんでもない嫌な人がいるんだと
その人はいつでも悪い言葉言ったり
悪い性格を持ってみんなの気持ちを悪くして暗くしちゃって
もう生きづらくすることはものすごく簡単なんですよ
それも嫉妬 怒りのエネルギーなんですね
ですから 例えば一人の人がとんでもない悪人がいるとしたっても
こちらには関係ないんだけど
あんた勝手に悪いことやってくださいと
悪い言葉言ってください
私に関係ないというのは正しいんだけど
関係ないといられないんですね
なんか汚い言葉なんか言ったりすると
ちょっと何か引っかかる言葉言っちゃうと
すぐここで我々も同じくらい考え方を出してしまっちゃうんですね
たとえ人が独り言でブスブス言いながら
この連中本当に迷惑ですねとか言ったならば
こういう耳に入った瞬間
もう気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですね
そうするとお互いにぶつかり合って
もうなかなか鬱陶しく生きていられない
それは我々は現代社会では知ってるんです
それ心はそういうふうな働きがあるんだと
ですから 今だったらお釈迦様の慈悲の言葉も人間に理解できるんです
昔だったらまあちょっと分からなかったかもしれません
でも一番昔の人々はもうあまり分からなくても
まあお釈迦様おっしゃったんだから
優しい心で生きていましょうと
それですごく平和で生きてきたんですよ
経済的な問題なく 住居の問題なく
人口の問題なく生きてたんですよ
この住居の問題 人口の問題
経済問題 健康の問題 今現代人にしかないんですから
昔の仏教の国々ではそれはほとんどなかったんです
今も少ないんですよ 初期仏教を実践している国々ではそういう問題なんか
ただ豊かというわけでもないんですよ
日本の食堂で見ると豊かというわけじゃないんです
それでもすごく気持ちよく
楽にストレス何もなく生きてるんだから
それはやっぱり悪いことをしてはいけないと
人に嫉妬してはいけないんだとという気持ちで生きてるんだからなんですね
ということで まあ慈悲のような言葉から見ても
現代社会にも我々にも本当の意味
釈尊おっしゃった行動の科学的な意味を理解できると思います
そこでもし釈尊の教えを理解して実践しようとか思うならば
私はそれを宗教だ 宗教だ
やったら何かいろいろ御利益あるんだという
こういう迷信でやってほしくないんです
すごく明るく元気で ごく普通の我々はお医者さんの薬をいただいて飲むような感じで
もう体にいい食べ物を店に行って買って食べてるような感じで
ごく普通に普通の知識人で常識人で実行していただければ
それは正しい実行なんですよ
いわゆる我々の日常の生き方とかけらでも引き離してはいけないんです
生きるか生きることそのものが仏教でなければいけないということは
釈尊のメッセージなんですね
人生と違うものではないんです
毎日の生き方が仏道なんですよ
ですから
どう人と接近すればいいですか？どのように仕事をすればいいんですか？どのように家庭の問題解決すればいいんですか？どのように子どもを育てればいいんですか
？どのように旦那の面倒見ればいいんですか？どのように奥さんの面倒見ればいいんですか？とか
そういうのを明確にお釈迦様はおっしゃっているし
それどこでも迷信的な奥さんがこういう呪文を唱えなくちゃ家庭は平和になりませんよという一言葉もないんです
お札を買ってきて うちにちゃんと飾っておかなくちゃ
この家は幸福になりませんとかね
商売繁盛にはこういうお札を使ってくださいとか
一言葉もおっしゃったことないんですよ
お釈迦様は商売繁盛したければ
こう言うんですよ 汗たらして働きなさいと
ちゃんとどれぐらい収入入るか
どれぐらい収入でき お金が出ていくかと
ちゃんと気をつけなさいと
入るお金はむちゃくちゃ使うなと
それを半分ぐらい収入の半分ぐらい投資しなさいと
半分投資しなさいと言ってるんです
収入が入ったら その残り半分の一部で生活しなさいと
残り４分の１は貯金しなさいと
何かあったら使うために
なぜならば 人間にどんな不幸が舞い込んでくるかわからない
その時はやっぱりお金がなければ困るでしょうに
ですから 何かあったら使うために 4分の1を使いなさいと
だからすごい科学的な教えではないんですかね
それで宗教になっちゃうと
お祈りすれば商売上手くいくんだとか
ああだこうだというのは
そういうのが宗教の世界で
お釈迦様の教えじゃないんですね
ですから 私は釈迦さんの教えというのはすごい現代的だなとは思ってるので
それを皆様に紹介したいということだけで
でもうちょっとしたストーリー
これ前言ったかどうか分かりませんだけど
ストーリーを申し上げたいんだけど
あるすごいあの金持ちの一人息子がいたんです
インド お釈迦様の時代で
すごい元気な男の子で
でお釈迦様はまあこの若者やらいっぱい人が住んでたところで
まあどんどん話を順番で説明していたんですね
これこの人は真面目に話を聞いていて
お釈迦様は最終的には心は完全に清らかにする道を教えちゃうんですね
その完全に清らかにする道を教えたところで
本人がそれをやりたいんですね
若いんだから でもその場合はもういろんな束縛から心を
もういろんな社会のことからちょっと自分を離れて隔離して
一人静かにやらなくちゃいけない
心澄める仕事だから そうすると彼が思ったのは
やっぱりお釈迦様のところに入って出家して修行しなきゃ
この解脱というものは体験できないだろうと思って
それで頭のいい子で でお釈迦様はみんな帰ってからお釈迦様のところに行って
私はお釈迦様今おっしゃった通りに解脱を体験したいんだと
ですからどうか出家してくださいと言ったら
お釈迦様はどう言ったかというと
君 両親に聞いたんですか？と
両親に断ったんですか？と
言ったら いえ 両親には言ってないんだと
ダメですよと ちゃんとお母さんお父さんにお父さんに行って行き言いなさいと
行って許可得なさいと
はい わかりました お父さんだったら
お母さん 私が言うこと何でもやってくれるんだと
その威張っちゃって 一人息子だから
で うちに入ってお父さんにお母さんに言うんですね
私はこういうすごい教えを聞きましたから
それをやってみたいんだと
ですから出家しますと
で 許してくださいと言ったら
両親がこう言うんですね
あなたはたとえ何かあって死んで私たちから離れていくことさえ我々は嫌ですよと
死んじゃったら人は自分から離れていくのは当たり前だから
それ止まること誰もできませんだから
あなたは死んでから私たちから離れていくことさえ
我々にとっては嫌ですよと
生きているあなたはどうやって話すことできるんですか？と
絶対許せませんと こんなにお金があるんだから
思い存分あなたと遊べるんだから
思い存分生活できるんだから
その生活しなさいと言ったら
もうこの子も聞かない
頑固で でもう人前に行ったり来たり
もうもうあまり話は通じない
それでこの人はもう断食するんです
じゃあ私は出家だけ許してくれなきゃ
もうご飯も食べないんだと
ご飯食べない で １日待ったら
あの子は全然苦労っていうのは全然知らないんだから １
日ぐらい我慢するだろうと思って
お母さん待ってるんですよ
いろんな美味しいもの作って置いておくんです
もうもうそろそろ音上げるだろうと思って
でももう全然食べない
で ２日 ３日経つと いくらなんでも両親がものすごい心配なんですね
どうなることか これは全然いくら美味しいもの作った食べないんだと
心配でしょうがなくて
で 自分言うことは聞かない
私は死にますと 食べませんと言ってるんだから
言ったらその人の友達に言ったんですね
お願いしますから なんとかこのこの子にご飯食べるように言ってくださいと
友達が行って話しちゃうんで
話したらもう何やってるんですか？そんなことやめた方がいいんじゃないかと
一緒に遊びましょうと
友達にも言うんです それはダメですと
私はもう決めたことやりますと
両親が出家許してくれなかったら
私は死にますよと それもう決まったんだからと言ったら
友達はこう考えちゃうんで
やっぱり友達はよく知ってるんだから
やっぱりこの人はもうやるつもりだよと
で 両親に今日言うんですよ
で あなた方はね そういう頑固でいると
この子はもうこの人はもう確実に死ぬかもしれませんと
ですから 結局大事な息子は失いますよと
出家しちゃったら家を出るかもしれませんだけど
どこかにいるんだから
自分の息子が それぐらいでも我慢して命を助けてあげてくださいと
ですから 死ぬよりは出家でもして生活するのはもういいことだから
それを理解してわかりましたと
で そこで許可を得たんです
それで彼がすぐもう許可を得て
すぐもう家を出て出家して
早く修行して みんな若い人々いたんですね
まあいくらかその思い存分やって
もうもう何て言いますか
気が晴れたら来るでしょうと
ですから 少しやらせてあげなさいということで戻るところが真面目に修行して悟ったんですね
完全に悟ったら家に戻ることはないんです
そこで若い すごい若い元気な子が出家して悟って落ち着いて生活して
そこである ある国に行ったんです
言ったら国の人々は その人を見てびっくりするんですよ
こんなに元気で こんなに美しい若い人はなんで出家しているんですかと
その国の国王もそれ聞いて普通行者っていうのは年取ってボロボロの体でもうやることなくてやってるんだけど
なんでこの若者はやってるんですかと
王様国王が聞いて その人に会って
我々知ってる限りは 人は出家するのは財産がなくなった時
重病で病気が治らない時
あるいは自分の親戚みんなもう何とか惨事があって死にまして
自分がもう一人になった時とか
あるいはやること終わってもう年取ってやることない時とかね
そういう時だよと なんであなたはそんなに若いのに出家して
どんなひどい目に遭ったんですか？と言ったら
この王様にすごい長い説法をするんですよ
で 私にとってはこの財産なくなったとかね
病気になったとかね そんなことは何もないんだと
私はもう真理を知りたく出家しているんだと
すごい素晴らしい説法なんですけど
説法して王様も納得いくんですね
そこで私は皆様に言いたいのは
こういうのはあの なんか仏道っていうのは
そういうなんか社会から逃げ道
社会の負け犬たちのたまり場ということではないと
仏教っていうのは普通宗教っていうのはなんか社会生活うまくいかない
家庭はうまくいかない
もう仕事はうまくできない
もうなんとかあるいは癌でも何か病気になっちゃって
もうもう見込みがかね
それでお手上げ状態で
まあどこか逃げ道というかね
心の支えというか そういうちょっとした慰めのようなことなんです
ですから 私はそれを悪い言葉で負け犬たちのたまり場という言葉で表現しているんです
僕はその言葉で私は何が言いたがっているかとわかるだろうと思いますよ
現代社会では これ日本だけじゃないんですよ
社会に溶け込めない 社会人とうまく筋が合って生活できない人々が
そういう辺とこりんなことを探し求めて行っちゃうんですよ
ですから 現代流行っている宗教というのは
ほとんどもうヨーロッパからいっぱい宗教が輸入されますけど
ほとんどこのちょっと見ると変というかおかしいというか
そういうことあるんですよ
なんか変なことばっかりやっていて
社会にちょっと合わないことばっかりやっていて
社会の常識から外れて
そういうことを見ると
現代人もやっぱり宗教というのは変なものだと勘違いするんです
それも当たり前で 変な人々がやっているんだから
変なものであることは当たり前なんです
ですから 釈尊の道は 仏道っていうのは
このもう負け犬たちのたまり場ということではなくて
社会で十分頑張ることできる勝利者のさらに優れているチャレンジなんですよ
いわゆる今の成功ではもう納得いかないで
もっと人間に高度なことにチャレンジできないかと
ただご飯食べて会社に行って仕事をして
それでまあ年取って死ぬと
それぐらいでしょう 一般の我々の人生の循環というのは
小さい時は勉強する それから仕事を見つかる
それから会社に毎日行く
途中で結婚する 子供が生まれたらその面倒を見る
もう退職したら まあそれでまあなんとかなんとかで
もう写真でも撮りながら
それで年取ってあの 死んでしまうと
で この何て言いますか
よくね 男性の場合はね
年取ったら大変 この写真家なんかいっぱい出ますからね
一生懸命厳密に仕事をした経験がありますから
立派なもんですよ もう年取って六十五歳で七十歳で写真始めたら
それでも五年ぐらい写真撮り始めちゃうと結構いい写真撮りますよ
それはまあずっと仕事をしてきちんとした人生ね
出来上がってるんだから
やることはきちんとやりますけど
それでいろいろ展覧会やらいろんなものを出したりします
それは大変幸福なことの幸福なんですね
でも もうちょっと離れてみると
なんかつまらないでしょうし
そんなことを写真ばっかり撮って
それで病気になって やがて人生終わってしまっちゃう
だからそれだけで満足しないでもうちょっとチャレンジしてみようと
だから世の中で誰にでも学校に行ったらきちんとシステムができているんだから勉強できる
経済システムがきちんとできるできているんだから
頭おかしくなければ誰にでもちゃんと仕事できる
日本の女性にしても みんな美人ばっかりだから
もう結婚というのは全然難しいことなんでもないし
ですから まあそんな人生に困る必要ないと私は思いますよ
ちょっと手足動かせば収入入りますから
なんでそれだけで満足しているんですかと
そこをちょっとそれだけで満足しないで
もっと意味があるものはないんですかと
というこの普通の人生は完璧にできる
そういう人々はよりプラスアルファで何かにチャレンジすると
真理を目指してチャレンジをするという
すごい明るい道であって
勝利者の道なんです お釈迦様はきちんとこの仏道は勝利者の道だよとはっきりと言っているんですよ
なぜかというと お釈迦様の時代でも
インドではこの社会で負けたらどこかの宗教団体に入って出家する
宗教は六十四ぐらいありましたから
いろんな宗教あったんです
それは自分一人で家出したっても
それまた宗教だと認める世界でしたからね
そうすると あっちこっちの行者たちがみんな何か問題持ちなんですね
何か問題持ち その問題なかったならば
サイケデリック宗教と関係なしと
そうすると宗教から何か大事な発見はできないでしょうね
所詮サイキックで問題持っているんだからうまくいかないということで
こちらでうまくいかない人はこちらでもうまくいかないんですね
そういうことで 私はもう仏教というのはきちんと現代人に通用するんだと
でも何かに負けちゃって
何もできなくできない人々がやっても大した成果はないんですよ
よっぽど苦労するんです
まあそういうことで そのあのあの
あの若者もラッタパーラという名前なんですけど
この私は別に負け犬じゃないんだとということを王様にちゃんと言ったんですね
私に別に何か問題あったわけじゃない
ただただ親言う通りに人生やったっても全くつまらなくて同じパターンでしょうしと
辞めたら人生見えますから
将来はどうなるかと まあそうはなりたくないんだと
もっと何か立派なものあるかないか探したいというふうな
すごいチャレンジ精神に満ちた人で
負け犬ではなかったんですね
お釈迦様のこの80代の弟子たちがみんな一人も負け犬ではなかったんです
みんなもう在家としてはすごい立派な人々でしたから
まあ人生失敗した人々もお釈迦様のところに行って大変幸福を味わったんだけど
ほとんどの人々がみんな立派でしたから
一人バックラというお坊さんがいて
その人がまあストーリーはなんかちょっと信じ難いところもありますけど
で 生まれた時はこの家はものすごい幸福になったみたいですね
あまりにももう幸福になってしまって
あまりにもその人の徳で
そこでこの海か川かわかりませんだけど
遊んでいる途中で この子どもがなんか魚に食べられたんだと
飲み込まれたんだと 魚はパクッと飲んだことは飲み干したけど
ものすごい徳の高い人を飲み込んじゃったんだから
もうもういられなくなって
すぐ他のところでこの漁師たちの網にかかったと
網にかかったところで
まあそれある人がそれを見て
すごい大きな魚で すごい金持ちの人がものすごい金持ちの人が
自分にはものすごい魚必要ですから
全部いっぺんに買ってしまって
でお腹を切ってみたところで
無事に赤ちゃんがいるんだと
それでそのうちには子どもがいなかった
あ これもらったもんだと
もうこれは授かりもんだと思って
大騒ぎして もう大変お祭りして子どもを育てるようになったんです
そこで話を聞いて あの家庭はこれ魚にすごい悲しがってるでしょ
それ私の子供だよと いて
これ喧嘩になっちゃったんです
ものすごい金持ちの家同士で
それで王様のところに行ったそうで
王様がいろいろ情報を探してみたら
やっぱり二人とも言ってることは正しいし
産んだうちがありまして
そのうちの子供だというのは
それもそれは正しいし
でもこの人は魚買ったところで
魚の中に入っているものは自分のものじゃないと言えないでしょうに
だからこの人ので 私たちは買ったものだから
もう私たちの子どもにあげませんと
という権利もあるでしょうに
いくら上お金いりませんと
売りませんだからと言っちゃえばそれで終わりです
王様はどうしようもないんですね
そこで王様は決めたんですね
じゃあ一年間 あなたはこの子の面倒を見てください
次の一年間 このうちで面倒見てください
また次の一年間 そういうふうに両親が四人ついちゃったんです
で まあ贅沢に育てられる
この二つの家もお金持ちの家で
それぐらい贅沢に育てたその人がもうあまりにも飽きちゃったんですね
贅沢に これだけではもう人生つまらないんだと
中国的な贅沢で やっぱり真理って何か
なんで人生ってどういうものかと探さなくちゃいけないと
で お釈迦様に出会って出家しちゃうんですね
何か 何かなくて 何か困って出家したわけじゃないんです
そこでその人どれほど健康的かというと
この八十歳になったところで言った言葉が残っているんですね
私はあの咳一つ立てるぐらいでも
病気になったこと 今八十歳までないんだと
それぐらい健康な体なんです
またいろいろ自分の徳を言っていたんだけどね
うちではこういうこういう生活しましたと
出家しても自分の徳ですか
このいろんな恵まれた生活したことはもう止まらなかったんだと
出家してからもう彼がほとんどもう一日二日一枚衣着たらまた新しいものをもらっちゃう
誰かから そうするとそれを着る
それを着ると前着たもの
衣は昔インドでは服っていうのは大変高価なもので
糸から手で作らなくちゃいけないんだから
それで他のお坊さんたちが衣なくなっちゃうなると
どうせあのお坊さんのところに行ったら必ずしも下着はもらえます
下がりといったっても
もう一日二日しか着てないもので
それぐらい贅沢な生活でしたからね
ですから そういういろんなストーリーあるんですよ
そのどんなストーリーしたっても
一つもこの人生は台無しになってどうしようもなくなった人々が逃げた場所ではなかったんですね
駆け込み寺ではなかったんです
じゃあ そういうと 仏教は駆け込み寺でなかったならば
なんか失礼な宗教ではないかと思うかもしれません
そうでもないんです それ駆け込み
駆け込み寺の仕事もちゃんとやっていたんです
人が悩んでると すぐそれも助けてあげる
だから悩んでる人はすぐお釈迦様のところに行ったし
問題があった人はすぐそこに行っちゃうし
今問題があるんだから
これ釈尊に会わなくちゃいけないんだと
ですから 両方の役をやっていたんだから
もう現代我々も一番成功で幸福できている人々もいて
そうでない人々もいる
ですから どっちにでも役に立つんじゃないかなと
どの不幸の人の例を僕はこの前の講演で言ったと言いますけど
どっちかは覚えてないんだけど
このある女の人がこの自分の家の奴隷と召使と駆け落ちして
で そこでまあ殺されるんだから
この奴隷の人は逃げちゃったんですね
女の子も後ろから来て
それですごい貧しい生活していたんです
そこで子供がお腹に入っちゃったらまた心配で
やっぱり親のところに行きましょうと
言ったら旦那は断る ダメですよと
行ったら殺されますよと
私は殺されてほしくないんだと
でも旦那が行かないんだから一人で行く
一人で行くと 途中で山の森の真ん中で子供を産んじゃう
旦那さんうち戻ってきたら人奥さんがいない
でももう追っかけていく
追っかけてたら まあ森の真ん中で一人で子供が産んで
ものすごいお嬢様育ちなんですけど
それでまあ子供が産みましたからね
帰りましょうと で 帰っちゃう
それで番目の子供は授かる
で また家に戻りたくなる
で その日はもうちょっと先に出てきちゃう
そしたらもう旦那さんも後でうちに仕事終わって帰ったら
もう奥さんがいないんだから
もう探しに行ったところで
もう森の真ん中で見つかるんですね
見つかって じゃあ帰ろうと
と いろいろ言っちゃうところで大雨が降る
帰るとこじゃない 大雨が降るだけじゃなくて
また森の真ん中で陣痛が始まっちゃう
そうすると じゃあもう分かりました
もうすぐ私は何か屋根を作ってあげますからと言って
あの枝を切り切ろうと思って行ったところで
そこでコブラですか 蛇にかまれて死んでしまっちゃうね
旦那が 奥さんが陣痛で苦しんですっごい夜までスクロールですからね
で この旦那が来るまで待って帰ってこない
そこですっごい雨の中で子供を子供を産んで
子供二人を自分のお腹の中につけて
動物みたいに手足で四つの足でこうやって子供守っているんですね
雨に濡れないようにと
その日でその場で生まれた赤ちゃんと一緒に
いて もう旦那に対するすごい腹が立って
もう何やってるんですかと
で 朝起きてもう旦那探したところでもう死んでるんですね
それすごいショックでしょうね
で 彼女はそのまままあしょうがない
もう家に戻ると自分の家に戻るしか意味がないと思って
川に川を渡ろうと思ったら川が洪水になって渡れない
たらこの前の年で生まれた子供を持ってこっち置いて
じゃああなたはこっちちょっと待ってくださいと言って
赤ちゃんを抱っこして川を渡っちゃうんですね
川渡って向こう側に赤ちゃんを置いてまた戻る
真ん中に戻っちゃったら
もうでっかいワシが来て子供を狙ってるんです
子供を狙ってると これしょうがなくても追い出さなくちゃいけない
ものすごい大きい声で手を叩いて鳥を追い払おうとするんですね
そうすると あのちっちゃな子が待ってる側
お母さん呼んでるんだと思って川に落ちちゃって
もう川に流されていっちゃう
そういう瞬間で取りかけて子供捕まってみんな死んじゃったんです
一日に それぐらいはショックは女の人には耐えられないんです
それで彼女は頭狂っちゃったんです
狂っちゃって 自分の家に
行こうと聞いたらまあみんなまあうちのこと聞くなと
そのうちのことは聞くなと
どういうことかといったら
まあこの大雨で雷が落ちて
両親も弟 兄貴がいたんだけど
三人も死んじゃったと
そうすると自分に財産もない
もう でもう頼りもない
で 頭が狂っちゃって まあ当然なことに
で 服も着ていない 全部もう脱がせちゃって
もう完全にもう狂っちゃって
で みんなまあ子供たちは石を投げる
あっち行けこっち行けというわ
もう大変な状態で そこである人がまあ彼女にもうお釈迦様いるところにちょっと行けるようにあっち行けばどうですかと
勢いにしたんですね お寺に入るを知ると
もう信者さんたちがこっち来るなと
もう裸の女の人だから
行ったら遠く説法しているお釈迦様はまあこの人通してくださいと通してもらうんですね
で 通ってくるといきなりお釈迦様は娘という呼んだんですね
娘さんいらっしゃいと
お釈迦様は娘さんと言った途端
彼女心はいきなりもう明るくなったんですね
いわゆる父親に会ったんだから
全く同じ愛情で 父親の愛情でおいでください
だからもう助けてあげますよということでしょうね
娘さんにとってはもう父親のところに行ったならば
もう全部ほっとするでしょうね
あの一言葉で彼女の心はいきなり明るくなって体見たら裸で
で それですぐもうしゃがんだんだけど
それで信者さんから服をもらって
ちょっと着て それで説法を聞いて
で 行くところがないんだから
そのままお釈迦様のところに泊まった
出家して で 彼女はそれからちゃんと仏教を勉強して
修行して完全に悟ったんです
悟って彼女はおっしゃったお経文もちゃんと経典に残っているんです
それからもう大なる偉大なる阿羅漢たちの一人なんですよ
だからやっぱり心の悩みを解決する道がお釈迦様は持っていたんですよ
だからちゃんと知っていたんですね
この人はもう誰かに頼りたい
もうみんなに頼った頼ったものは全部なくなった
だから真理は頼るなという真理なんですよ
何かに頼ったらすごい不幸がそこに待ってるんだと
でもそれを教えるよりは
あなたもうお父さんに頼っていた
旦那に頼っていた子供に頼っていたみんな亡くなって頼るものはないよと言ったっても意味がないんです
ですから まあ娘いらっしゃいと
まあ娘って日本語ではあまり呼べませんだけど
まあ向こうの我々の言葉だったらもう娘を娘と呼ぶんですね
ものすごい可愛い愛らしい言葉なんですよ
それともすぐあ この人は私に何かしてくれるだろうと
で たったそれで心は清らかになって
まあ修行できたし で 後でまあ彼女にこの悟るためにもう心は治って
もう仏性になったところで
彼女のおっしゃったのは我々に頼るには我々の子供は我々の頼りにならないんだと
我々の両親にも我々の親戚の誰にも我々を助けてくれることはできませんと
もう我々は消滅変化している死に覆われているんだと
誰からも頼りがないんだと
自分に自分しかないということ
自分で自分の心を清らかにしなくちゃいけないと
で それを後で教えたんですけどね
で だから思う存分 かのうが無常ということを知っていたんだからね
もう悟っただろうと思いますけど
ですから この仏教では
このそういう頼りない人々もちゃんと助けてあげるんです
また あるもう一人ストーリーがありまして
うん ある家庭で子どもがいたんです
ちっちゃな子どもがいたんだけど
母がすぐ亡くなったんです
子どもはなかなか育てられない
その旦那が他の女の人を連れてくるんです
その人はこの子どもの面倒を見て育てて
まあ頑張っている途中で自分も妊娠しちゃうんですね
自分が妊娠して子どもが産んじゃったら
自分の子どもはかわいくて
よその子はもう本当にもう憎たらしく見えちゃうんですね
どうせ子ども同士で喧嘩したりするはするし
まあ母が違うんだから
ちょっと激しい喧嘩もあるかもしれませんし
前の子は本当にストレス溜まってるんだから
自分の自分の母もいないし
お父さんももう新しく入ってきた女の人の面倒ばっかり見て
なんか自分は寄せ者にしたような感じがするし
ですから どうせ喧嘩したり
もういろんなもういたずらしたりしただろうと思いますよ
で この女の人がものすごくこの子は嫌で嫌で
旦那が旦那さんがどこか出て行ったところで
特にこの子どもを捕まえて墓場に連れて行ったんです
昔いろいろ墓場ありまして
火葬する火葬場もあったりして
遺体捨て場もあるんですね
その子はこの死んでる人の体にも全部手も足もつなげて置いて帰っちゃったんです
そうすると夜いろいろ動物が来るんだからね
いて遺体食べちゃいますから
どうせ新しい肉は先に食べるでしょうね
で そこでもうなんとか自分がまあ知らないと言っちゃえばね
もうあの子はもういつもいたずらばっかりで
私言うことも聞かない
あっち行ったりこっちやっているんだけども
探して見つからないと言ったら自分がOK でしょ
そういうことをしたんですね
で それはお釈迦様 ちゃんと自分の能力で超能力ありましたけどね
まあそれで知って あ あの子はもう大変だと
いって 自分一人で遺体捨て場に行って
あの子供を連れていて
お寺に連れて行ったんです
連れて行って もうその親の許可何もなしに出家されたんです
捨てた子だから 普通だったら親の許可ないと出家できないんです
その子を出家させて すごく大事に面倒見てあげて
みんな他のお坊さんたちにも面倒見てあげなさいと
だからみんなちっちゃな子供だからね
まあ大変かわいくて もう面倒見てあげて
出家させていろいろ教えてあげて
小さい時悟ったんですよ
年取るまでは待てない
すごい小さいと で 悟ったんだけど
まだ子供だから 他のお坊さんたちはいろいろからかったり遊んだりする
悟った人っていうのは尊い人なんですね
だからその人にからかったりすると大変罪が多いんですよ
ですからお釈迦さんはこれ心配ですね
この子供悟ってるんだからね
他の人々は年は取ってるんだけど
まだまだ修行中で みんな修行中の連中は一番からかったりするんだから
この人々はもう罪を犯してるんだと
ですから これ何とかしなくちゃいけないんだと思って
みんなの前であのちっちゃな沙弥を呼んで
こっちいらっしゃいと自分のところに
ほんでこの沙弥ははいと言ってお釈迦様の前に来たら
じゃああなたにクイズ出しますと
そしたら分かりましたと
そしたら１って何ですか？と聞くんです
言ったらもう仏教の真理にとって
もう１はこういうものが先生にする
じゃあ２は何ですか？と
2つと言えば これしか存在の中で 2つはないと答えるんです
じゃあ 3つと言えば何ですかと
言えば ものすごく これはもう誰にも答えられないんですよ
じゃあ 3つっていうのはこういうものだと
この子供は答えるんです
そこで１０まで行くんですよ
言ったらみんなの前で答えたんだから
みんな驚くんですね こんな知恵はどこからあるんですかと
そしたらみんなの前で今日からこの子は一人前の比丘として認めますと
ですから あなた方はこの沙弥だと
もう沙弥ではないんだと
今日からは と言って 年下なのにこの得度式というか
この比丘戒を授けてあげたんですね
ですから 子供だとからかうなと
この人はもう完全に煩悩をなくして心を清らかにしている人ですよと
それでやっとその子供をからかわれることはなくなったんですね
だから人の面倒を見るととことんそこのところまで見るんです
そこでお釈迦様 自分の息子も出家しましたし
息子も小さい時出家してたんですよ
その時は自分で自分の息子だから親に聞かないで
で 息子はもうお父さんと一緒に御寺に戻った
戻ったらどう出家したら？と聞いたら
まあお父さんに言われるんだからと
はいと言って行ったら
お釈迦様は自分で出家しなかったんですね
自分のそばに置いておかなかったんです
で 他のサーリプッタ尊者に任せたんですね
サーリプッタ尊者にこの子を出家させてくださいと言って
だから先生はサーリプッタ尊者
お釈迦様じゃないんです
それどういうことかと
やっぱりあれは親の心なんですね
親と一緒にいると甘えたりするんですね
ですから ちょっと厳しいところに入れてあげようではないかと
でも選んだのは知恵の第一人者
その時でも じゃあ自分の子供を任すならば
知恵の第一人者に任せてあげようと
でも自分がもっと知恵があったんだけど
自分が面倒見ちゃうと
どうせこの子は甘えるかもしれませんし
他の人々から批判されるかもしれませんが
いくらお釈迦様でもいつでも子供と一緒だよと
一度も一緒にいなかったんです
自分の子供と だからその時でも
きちんと自分の子供でも育てる時はきちんと方法を知って育てて
でも心配です でも心配でいたって
もし私のお父さんがお釈迦様だよと威張っちゃったら困るでしょ
言ったらたまに会う たまに元気を見る
見る行く いでどうですか？あなたは行儀よくやってるんですか？と
年上の人々をちゃんと尊敬してるんですか？と
よくそればっかし聞くんですね
だから年上の人々にちゃんと頭下げて尊敬して生活してるんですか？と
言ったら もうラーフラ尊者もはい
そうですと だから仏教というのはすごい鋭い知識人の教えなんですけど
そういういろんな人に会うように
いつでもちゃんと面倒見てあげた教えなんです
そういうすごい素晴らしいストーリーというのはたくさんあるんです
なかなか現代 このそういう釈尊の本当のストーリーはほとんどみんなあまり気にしないというか
知らないというかね ですから
私は言いたいのは 我々現代社会はいくら発展して幸福になっていても
幸福な人々もいて なんか何か精神的な問題やらトラブルやらあって
なかなかうまくいかない人々もいるんですよ
で 皆さん最近知ってるでしょうとね
小さな子供でも殺人するところまでもうストレスたまったりして
わけもわからないことになっちゃってしまって
そういう現象までこの現代時代では現れるんですよ
じゃあそれは解決する道があるんですかね
この教育システムでは
今の経済システムでは人に優しい心を教える道があるんですかね
会社にしてももう弱肉強食でいかなくちゃいけない
学校に行っても戦って戦ってと怒りしかないでしょうに
我々の今生きている生かされているエネルギー
衝動っていうのは怒りだけなんですよ
負けてたまるかとかね
そうすると 怒りは固まって
もうもう何て言いますか
すごい結果出す可能性ありますよ
だから現に我々にそういう事実はあるんだから
何のことあってはいけないところから犯罪者が出てきたりするし
子供たちがちょっとふざけて遊んでるところで人が死んでしまっちゃうし
いくつかケースあったんだからね
子供たちが人を殺したりケースっていうのは一人一つだけじゃないんですね
廊下でこの不良者が何人か殺したケースもあったりして
それ我々の可愛い子供たちでしょ
どう見たっても何の顔見たら全然わからないんです
本当にかわいいし すごい元気で振り回ってますけど
でも心の中ですっごいストレスというか怒りというか
やりきれない感情が固まって固まって
それどこかに爆発してしまっちゃう
じゃあそこを解決する方法はありますかね
我々お母さんたちに自分の子供は悪い方向に行かないという保証がどこかありますかね
お母さんも自分のもう固定概念で固まっちゃって
自分の我が子は見えないんですね
可愛い可愛いしか見えないんですね
お父さんも我が子は見たこともないんですから
まあ夜遅くなって家に戻るんだから
どんな性格を持ってるか分からない
ですから やっぱり現代的にこの生命の論理
生きるということはどういうことかと
ちゃんと科学的に 知識的に我々は知る必要は確実にあるんです
単なる悪いことしたら罰が当たりますよと地獄に落ちますよと言ったって
そんな誰が信じるんで
そんなことは これお数読めてちゃんと呪文でも唱えたら全部万事解決するぞとかね
そういうのは誰も信じないと思いますよ
現代人は信じるならばおかしいというぐらいのことで
ですから ちゃんと科学的に心の働きと生命ってどういうものかと
どう生きていった方がいいんですかと
どのように生きていれば我々の
だからそのメッセージなんですね
釈尊が 2500年前でおっしゃったのは
ということで 私は仏教というのは現代社会には
社会にはきちんと通用するはずだろうと
ただ聞いてくれないだけで
聞いたらちゃんと通用するだろうと思います
決してこの時代遅れの教えではないと
ですから そのその人にすごい必要な教えがちゃんとありますよ
子供たちだったら子供たちに必要な教え
若者だったら若者に必要な教え
年取ってる人々だったら年取ってる人々に必要な教え
仕事終わってももう暇がある人々にはそれなりの道とかね
ちゃんとあるんです 順番に
それから一般的な社会問題いろいろ考えていますけど
で なんで我々の社会は経済的に豊かになっても
なかなか精神的に豊かにならない
犯罪っていうのはどんな国でももうむちゃくちゃあるんですね
なんで現代社会になっても
我々の戦争っていうのは絶えないんですかと
なんでこのあっちこっち人は殺すは殺されるは殺されるは
それ終わらないんですね
どれほど科学発展していたっても
飢えている人々はいっぱいいるんですよ
飢え死になる人々は 子供たちが毎日ものすごいたくさん飢え死になってるし
栄養失調っていうのはむちゃくちゃでしょうに
豊かになっているのはほんのわずかな国々だけで
それでも豊かといったっても
生きることは大変で大変で
皆様のことを考えたっても
毎日必死になって働かなきゃ大変危ないでしょ
収入が だから結局豊かな社会のことを見たっても
ただ食べることをもう住居
家賃を払うこと 食べること
それぐらいのことで精一杯
他の暇は全くない だから何かどこかでおかしいんですね
豊かだったらいっぱい余裕があって
暇があって なんか人生はものすごく楽しめるべきでしょうに
家族仲良くしてとか そういう暇さえない
お父さんにも子供たちと遊ぶ暇がない
お母さんにもない だからみんなバラバラになって
それぞれ勝手に大きくなるだけで
だからお互いに話は通じてない
旦那が何考えてるか奥さんが分からない
奥さんが何考えるとか旦那さんが分からないと
子供は何考えてるか先生も分からないし
両親も分からないし ですからなんかすごく豊かな社会見ても
なんかどこかでちょっとガタガタでおかしいし
それから我々現代人が威張ってますけど
科学発展しているんだとか
すごい農業なんかは今ものすごい発展しているんだから
DNA までカラクリして素晴らしいあの新品質改良ですか
なんとかわけのわからないことをやってるんだとかね
じゃあ地球の食糧問題解決してるんですかね？そんなに発展してるんだったら
全然解決してないでしょうに
そんなに情報化社会で全てのインターネットやらああだこうだとか
いろんなくだらないものいっぱいあって
誰でも自由に情報も絡み合ったりしているんだと威張ってるんだけど
じゃあ世界から戦争はなくなってるんですかね？かわいそうな人々が殺されること
悪い政治家が現れてきて
国 国民をいじめることはなくなってるんですかね
一つもなくなってないでしょうに
ただ単に まあ我々はもう優れてるんだ
発展しているんだとか
なんか自分一人勝手に自慢してるだけだと私には言えるんですよ
私は社会と関係ないんだから
出家だから全く関係ないんだからそういうこと言えるんだけどね
ですから そこにその原因
なぜこうなってるかと
その原因 誰も見つかろうとしない
なぜ我々はここまで経済的に成長しているのに
いまだに貧乏性で悩んでるんですかと
そうすると皆様気持ち悪くなるかもしれません
だけど やっぱり毎日仕事しなきゃ危ないでしょうに
そうすると 1 日の給料で仕事している貧しい国々の世界と同じなんですよ
僕の国でも人はその日仕事しなきゃ次の日は食べ物なくなっちゃうんです
貧しいんです 日本といったってもそんながあったかなと僕は思いませんだけど
そんなお金の余裕があるとは思いませんだけどね
結構厳密に計算して 家計簿をちゃんと 一 一 一 書いたりして
で 苦労してるのはもう普通なんですよ
使うお金の量が違うかもしれませんよ
私の国の人は 100円ぐらいあれば
まあ 1 日ご飯食べてるかもしれませんし
日本では 100円では何も食べられませんしね
まあそれだけの差ですけど
で その何か原因あるんです
昔から今まで人間の心の中に
そこでお釈迦様は今この心の中にこの原因があるんだと
我々不幸にする原因は心の中にあるんだと
我々の生きる衝動がちょっとおかしいんだと
そのおかしいエネルギーで行動すると
結果はどうしてもおかしいんだと
それはもう正真正銘のことなんですね
それどういうことかというと
まず我々にあるのは欲と怒りなんですね
で 欲は欲あるだけで なんでこの欲ありますかと
それ何か意味があるんで
それわかってない ただみんなお金なければいけませんとか
たくさん儲からなくちゃいけないんだ
そればっかし考える ちょっとでも止まって
なんでたくさん儲からなくちゃいけないかと
そこら辺明確にしないんです
バリバリ仕事しなくちゃいけないと思うだけで
それなんでバリバリ仕事しなくちゃいけないんですかと
そこまでは考えないんですね
まあ子供たちはたまに考えちゃいますよ
勉強しろ勉強しろというと
何でですか？と聞くんです
でも 一人の大人にも答えられないんです
だから大人は変な答え出しちゃうんですよ
ちゃんと勉強しなきゃ
大学出なきゃいい仕事見つかりませんよと
じゃあいい仕事って何ですか？まあお父さんみたいにちゃんといい会社に入って仕事
お父さんの生き方見たってすごいくだらないでしょうに
朝早く仕事に行って 遅くなって帰って
また次の日朝早く行って
そこで奥さんにいつでも毎日怒られてとかね
子供から見れば やっぱりお母さんの方が力強くて
もう偉大なるお父さんの方が力ないんではないかとと見えるし
だからそうなりたく そういう風になりなさいということだから
子供は小さいんだから
元気があるんだから もっと何か大胆なことをやりたがっちゃうでしょうに
だからそういうメッセージないでしょ？だから納得いかない
それでも学校登校拒否したり色々ね
なったりするし だから我々はただ欲だけであって
勉強しなくちゃっていうのは欲だけであって
金儲けなくちゃっていうのは欲だけであって
それは何のためですか？どんな目的ありますか？それで何かいいことあるかないかとか
そこまでもうちょっと知識を働かせて考えない
だからいつでも落とし穴ばっかしで
これはもう日本であろうか
ヨーロッパであろうか
アメリカであろうか もうどんな国でも同じです
経済的に成長すると まあどこかでいろんなガタガタところはいっぱい現れてくる
今はもう発展し続けている中国にしたっても問題ばっかしで
香港にしたっても同じで
で 打倒ですか 中国の暴力団
何とかって じゃ 邪道 というなんか日本まで来て
なんか大変なことをやってるんだとかね
そういうのは経済的な豊かだから現れる問題でしょうに
だからいつでも我々社会っていうのはガタガタ状態なんですね
それはとにかく金儲けなくちゃという
ただそれだけで まあ女性のことにしたっても
とにかく美しくならなくちゃというふうなことで一生懸命頑張ったりするでしょうに
だからダイエットしていろいろなことをやって
美しく美しくと もうちょっと待って
あれ 何のためかと考えちゃうと
もう違う何か発展するかもしれません
ただ 自分の命 命まで危険にさらしてダイエットする必要あるかないかとかね
だから過食 恐食症です
何て言うか そこまで発展しちゃうし
本人がどれほど精神的にいじめるかというと
もう食べられなくなっちゃうんですね
それで美しくなるところか
もう骸骨になってしまっちゃうし
そこまで欲は何のためですか？と
ですから 我々は単なる欲と怒りで戦わなくちゃ
あるいは何か儲からなくちゃと
だからお釈迦様はもうちょっと考えなさいよと
何かやる行動する前に
もうちゃんともうこの順番で目的をちゃんと考えなさいよと
言ってるんです そこでまあ答え申し上げますけどもね
例えば子供は勉強しなさい
勉強しなさいというと
大きくなったらいい仕事見つかりますよとか
そんなことを言ったって意味がないんですよ
僕だったらもう勉強しなきゃ面白くないでしょ
ただそれしか言わないんで
別に欲何にもないんです
勉強しないでただ食べて遊んでるばっかで面白くないでしょ
そうすると別に欲も何にもなく
ただ面白いんだから勉強やると
そちらに競争もないし
何もない 面白いんだから別にもうとことんバリバリとやるだろうと思いますし
そうすると勉強自体全然ストレスはたまらない
そうすると仕事になって仕事をするところになっちゃったら
まあできるだけいい仕事にチャレンジしようと
いわゆるもう ちょっと激しいというか
競争 まあもう結局よく頑張れる仕事にチャレンジしようと
仕事はどうでも何でもいいんだけど
つまらない仕事だったらね
つまらないんだから いろんなチャレンジある仕事をやってみたらどうですかと
ちょっと不安あります
なんとか会社に入る仕事に
ちょっとまあいいんじゃないんで
そんなことでわからないこといっぱい勉強できるんだから
私だったらそういうふうに言うんですね
あの会社に入ったらすごい大きい会社だから給料はいいですよとかね
そんなくだらないことは言わない
ですから その答えっていうのは
欲を衝動にするんじゃなくて
日々充実して生きていられれば十分だよと
ですから 日々の生活は子供にもあって
若者にもあって 中年にも老年にもみんなにありますでしょうに
だから欲でなんかやっちゃうと
年取っちゃったらやることなくなっちゃう
欲だけ残っちゃって それでもう年取ったらすごい生きる
生きること苦しくなっちゃうんです
例えば男の場合はもうチャレンジして競争して競争して生きる怒りだけで生きていたんだと
怒りだけで生きていて
それで退職しちゃうでしょ
うちに帰ったところで
奥さんにこれは間違ってる
ここはこうでなくてこうではないか
これは掃除はちゃんとやってないんですかとか
いろいろもう言うんですよ
そこで奥さんと旦那さんがやっと一緒になったところでお互いに喧嘩になっちゃうんです
旦那さんが家にいると困るんだと
旦那さんもしょうがないんでしょうね
会社でもバリバリとやってきたんだから
かすかな失敗も許さないでやってきたんだから
その癖でうちに帰ったらもううちに戻るようになったところで
もう何見ても何かおかしく見えちゃうんですね
それでいちいち言っちゃうし
それでも奥さんにぶん殴られる可能性もあるし
だからそこは怒りだけで生きていたんだからそうなってきて
だから怒りと欲は良くないんだと
その代わりに日々充実して生活するということ
は衝動にする そうすると退職したっても
その日は充実して生きてるんだから
うちでもういると まあなんか面白くない
そうするとまあそれなりのうちのお手伝いしたりとか
奥さんと一緒に新しい料理でも勉強したりとか
いろいろなことはできますし
そこで競争もないし 欲もない
だからといってバカみたく怠けてるわけでもない
もう怠けることを仏教ではものすごく反対するんだから
怠けることはものすごい苦らいんだと
これは病気だから 毎日怠け状態が成長するんだと
ですから 僅かにでも怠けてはいけないんだと
休んではいいんだけど
怠けてはいけないんだと
ですから怠けないで頑張りますけど
それは欲で頑張ってるわけじゃない
怒りで頑張ってるわけじゃないと
だから経済成長もそういうふうに欲で経済成長すると
どこかで大変危険なことが待ってるんです
全部ダメになっちゃうんです
怒りで経済活動やっちゃうと
どこかでもやられちゃうんです
だから怒りと欲だけで現代経済システムが地球でできているんだから
全然幸福な状態になってない
貧しい人々はいっぱいいる
飢え死になる人々はいっぱいいる
これぐらい科学発展しているんだったらね
雨が降らない方にもそれなりの食料が行くようにとか
いくらでもできるでしょうに
地球規模で雨が降らないんだけど
そういう砂漠のでも その人々にも他の人々の役に立つことはいっぱいありますから
なんで地球規模でみんな仲良くしようというふうな経済システム出てこないんですかね
それは怒りと欲があるんだからなんですよ
隣の国をもとことん攻めてでも
自分たちだけ経済成長しようという怒りと欲
そうするとこちらは経済成長するどころか
こちらもガタガタで あちらもガタガタでお互いにもう共倒れになっちゃうんですね
この共倒れ現象で我々はずっと生きてきたんですよ
今でも目覚めた方がいいんじゃないかなと
今の時代でも いくらか地球のことをわかっているんだからね
そうすると共倒れではなくて
共に生きる道が仏道なんですよ
なぜ仏道かというと 他のところ見ると人はもう排除するんですよ
例えば 神を信じる人と信じない人というふうに排除するんです
仏教では信仰ないんだから
お釈迦様は信じろうが信じなかろうが
そこと関係なく あなたの行為によってあなたは結果得られますよと言っているんだから
人をところが生命一人も排除していないんです
それは一人の人を信じるか信じないか
それは関係ないんです
私は悪いこと 悪い人生をやっちゃうと悪い結果が得られるし
いい生活を持って素晴らしく行動すると
誰からも攻撃されなくて元気で生きていられるし
ですから いつでも教えは真理という立場でおっしゃっているんですね
で ちょっと触れてみたいところありますけど
この人間というのはいいことをしようと努力するのは我々の社会を見ると見えるんですね
例えばボランティア活動をなさっている
で いろんな国々へ行って
マザー・テレサみたいな
そういうところに行って
何とかしようとかね で
どこかで何か地震があったり何かあったらみんな行って
そこでそういう活動をやったり
そういうことはあるんですね
で それを見て ああ なるほど
立派な人間がいるんではないかと思ったりする
あれも私は仏教の立場から見ればおかしい現象なんですね
特別なボランティアグループがあるということはおかしい現象なんですよ
なんでボランティアグループある必要あるんですかと
生命である限り お互いに助け合うのは当たり前であって
それは人が呼吸することと同じであって
ボランティアはあってはならないんですよ
ボランティアという言葉さえ汚い言葉なんですよ
なぜかというと 我は私は金のために仕事をするんだと
金のために仕事しないんだったら
それはボランティアですよと
ということは お金のために仕事をするのは当たり前で
いわゆる自分のために
自分の欲のために ちょっと欲のためにではなくて
ちょっと変なことをするんだから
それはボランティアとという言葉になっていて
そんなことはあってはならないんですよ
世の中でボランティアは
なぜならば人を困っていると自分にできるだけのことをしてあげるのは
これは特別な道徳ではなくてなくてはならない
全く基本的なことなんです
ですから 私はボランティアという
まあ日本語でボランティアですけど
ボランティアという言葉自体も何か汚れている言葉ではないかなと思うぐらいなんですね
なんか人を助けたらちょっと威張って
私はボランティアやってるんだとかね
威張るところじゃないでしょ
当たり前のことをやってるんだから
それなら私は今日朝ごはん食べたよと威張ってもいいでしょうに
誰も朝ごはん食べたよと威張らないでしょ
当たり前のことをやってるんだから
そういう人助けっていうのはそれぐらい当たり前でなくてはならないんです
そうすると社会には問題ないんでしょうに
例えば 子供たちはいつでも親の管理の中にいるわけじゃない
電車に乗ったり あっちこっち行ったり
いろんなところに遊び回ったりする
どこでも大人がいっぱいいるし
みんな知らんふりなんです
子供はちょっと悪いことしたらちょっと厳しく叱らない
だから子供は自由自在
やりたい放題 だから悪くなったっても誰も責任持たない
もし社会の大人たちがみんな
子供を守るのは大人の仕事だと
親の仕事だけではないと
親はご飯食べさせてあげて
服を着させてあげて 寝かせてあげて
病気になっちゃったらもう面倒見てあげたりとか
そういう体の面倒を見るんであって
子供は社会のものだから
子供を大きくして社会人にするのは社会みんなの仕事だとという
これは当たり前だという感じになっちゃったら
子供はそんなに自分わがまま好き勝手には行動できなくなっちゃうんです
どこでも大人がいるんだから
やっぱり行儀よくしきたりを守って遊んだりする
で 子供は安心するんですよ
危険はどこにもないんだと
どうかちょっと遊んだところで
ちょっと怪我しちゃっても
そこら辺にいる誰かおばあちゃんおじいちゃんがちゃんと助けてくれるし
そうすると心配 親にも心配ないでしょうに
その場合は そういう社会なんですね
正しい社会っていうのは
そうすると問題起こると思いますか？大人がいると
どんな大人であろうか
学校の先生と自分の親ではなくて
もうこれやっちゃったら怒られるだろうと
だから行儀よく遊ぼうという気持ちが子供の心にあるならば
子供はどこに遊んでも安心安全であって
だから子供は悪い方向に行かない
あまりにもわがまま 脆弱だけで
あまりにも欲だけで生きてるんだから
我々社会っていうのは
今の地球っていうのはおかしくなってるんです
だから釈尊の言葉っていうのは
やっぱり愛情を持ってどんな生命も守ってあげようと
それは私たちの責任であって
やらなくちゃいけないことであると
そういうことで 私はものすごくボランティアってのはおかしいことだって
みんなすぐに驚くでしょうに
ボランティアという言葉自体が汚れているよと言ったら
何言ってるんですか その人たちに怒るかもしれません
私はちゃんとした理屈があって言ってるんです
それは簡単にわからないだけなんですけども
簡単に理解できないだけなんですけど
それでじゃあボランティアやってる方々から見ると
みんなストレス溜まってる
やりきれないと文句言って言ってくる
せっかくやってあげてるのに
その人々の態度が悪いと言ってくる
ボランティアに行ったところでいろいろもうひどい目に遭ったりする
なぜそういうことになってるんですかというと
やっぱり心で自我があるんですね
やってあげてるんではないかと
ボランティアしてるんではないかと
いわゆるうちで自分の国で仕事をしたらお金入るのに
それも置いといて 私はやってあげてるんではないかという
自我というか高慢というか
それは働いてるんですよ
そうじゃなくて やらせてもらってるんだということに変わらなくちゃいけないんですよ
ボランティアさせていただいてるんだと
ですから ボランティアして助けてあげてる人が感謝して
ありがとうございます
ありがとうございますと勇気持ちでやっちゃうと
向こう側は全く反応もしないし
もう抵抗もしないし スムーズに行っちゃうよ
何の危険もなく それでなんで一部の人だけボランティアしますかというと
こんなに人々はいっぱいいる国
世界 世界の中でみんな自分のこと以外のことをやりたがらないんです
やりたがらない だから世の中でどんなボランティアシステム
福祉システムできても
実況の幸福は消えません
消えるわけじゃないんです
やり方おかしいんだから
それだったら正しいやり方っていうのは
こういう科学的なやり方なんです
それで社会の道徳ということ
社会にいろいろ道徳の問題ありますね
で みんな宗教から離れていくんだけど
なかなか宗教から離れてもいいんだけど
なんか社会の道徳を守るのはちょっと難しいんですね
すみません いつでもいろんな犯罪があったり
いろんな問題があったりして
私たちもやっぱりすごく不安で生活していて
日本はそんなに危ない国ではないんだけど
まあ皆様ご存知のように
外国なんか行くとかなりもう危ないというか
危ないし なんでそんなに我々は現代的に法律は昔とよりものすごい民主主義的にきちんと法律できてできているならば
警察やらそういうシステムはバッチリとできているでしょうに
ありとあらゆる科学的なものを発展して
どんな犯罪でもすぐ見つかるようにいろんなことをできていて
例えばこの間テレビで見たんだけど
例えば人を殺したりして
この欠席なんかはきれいに洗っても全部見つかるような科学的な物質を作っているんですね
だからいくら洗っても
なんか特別なこの化学製品をこれ塗ってみたら
もうすごいピカピカ光っちゃうんですね
欠席あったところで目では見えない
まあそれぐらい犯罪した人を見つかるようなね
まあ方法を発展しているならば
問題に安心して寝られるでしょうに
でも寝られない それでも随分犯罪は起こる
平和がないと それどういうことかというと
みんなこの忘れてるんですね
ただ単に まあその時の怒りで人を殺しちゃえばそれでいいんじゃないかとかね
その時の欲で欲で人のものを奪っちゃえばいいんじゃないかとかね
それでそれを抑えるために
単なる法律で罰 法律で決めますと
それで社会 人間の心は消えるわけじゃないでしょうに
それだったら解決方法っていうのは
小さい時からも怒りで行動するとこういう風なことがありますよと
科学的に心の方法を教えてあげて教えてあげることなんですよ
欲だけであなたは今いろんなことをやってますけど
それでこういうこういう風な嫌な人間になりますよと
ですから 子供の時も学校ででもこの心の働きを教えてあげて
怒りでこうなります 欲でこうなりますと
ですから人は自由に行動するのはいいんだけど
それは明るく元気で仲良くするためのやるものでありますよと
そういう心の法則は理解しない限りは
世の中では犯罪は消えることはないんです
ということは 我々はいつでも犯罪はできればやる人々なんですよ
ただ法律が怖くて 体罰は怖くてやってないだけ
だからもう安心することはできない
自分に自分の心についても安心することはできないでしょうに
この人は子供だから大丈夫だとかね
この人は女の人だから大丈夫だとか安心することはできないんですよ
ちょっとこの何て言いますか
オケションですか このそういう場があったら何やるかわからない
我々の心っていうのはそれぐらい恐ろしい心を持っていて
全然心自体は育ててないんです
どんなに現代人にはどんな人にも
私だったら絶対犯罪は起こせませんと
私だったら絶対横領というか悪い方向でお金は取りませんというふうに自信がありますかと
そうはないんでしょう
私だったら絶対もう怒って人を殴ったり
人を殺したりはしませんと
もし年取ったところでそう言えるかもしれません
それは何ですかといったら
もう年だからということなんです
あるいは私は全然お金のからくりとか横領とかしたことはないんですよという人がいるかもしれませんよ
僕みたいなものすごい悪口の人が前に聞いたら
僕は聞くんです それは何ですか？と聞いたら
本当のところできなかったんだからなんですって
自分の仕事関係ではね
俺はできる仕事を見つかっちゃったらやっちゃいます
どんな立派な人でも そういう証拠はいくらでもあるでしょう
社会人としてはもう最高な立派な人なんですけど
最高な立派なところに仕事をしているんだけど
多く単位でもう彼の誤魔化をしている
我々は普通のサラリーマンだからもう全然そんなことやったことはない
だから心は清らかですかと
そうじゃなくてできないんだからなんです
ですから私が言うのは
悪い言葉でわかりやすい言葉で言うならば
人間誰でも歩く犯罪者なんですよ
ただ起こしてない 犯罪は起こしてない
犯罪を起こす可能性を持っている
その場合はどんな言葉でいいかわかりませんだけど
この予備軍みたいな 犯罪の予備軍みたいなもんなんですね
お釈迦様はそんな社会話ではなくて
心の中の問題で解決しちゃうんですね
私がたとえバレてもバレなくても悪いことをしたら私の心のエネルギーで私は悪い結果が得られるんだと
それは真理ですよと たとえ隠れてでも悪いことをしたら私の心が私を責めるんだと
そうすると私に自由に明るく生きることができなくなっちゃうんだと
みんな隠れて悪いことをするんだけど
隠れて悪いことをするたびに生き方はちょっとガタガタしちゃうでしょうに
例えば男の人はあっちこっち行っていろんな不倫したりすると
すぐ奥さんにバレちゃうんですね
なぜバレちゃうかというと
余計に親切とか なんか特別にプレゼント買ってくれるとかね
で もうバレちゃうんですね
なんか今日はおかしいんだよと
ということは 全然奥様がそれ知らないかもしれませんだけど
隠れてでも悪いことしちゃったら生き方がそこでちょっと引っかかっちゃうんですよ
自由に堂々と生きていられないんです
奥さんが何か言っちゃったらもういきなり喧嘩できないんです
何だお前はこんなこと言うんですかと
弱いんです お互いに夫婦だからやりたい放題喧嘩したっても別になんのこともないんだけど
なかなかできないのはどこかで弱みがあって
だから夫婦平等でなくなっちゃうんです
ですから お釈迦様が言うのは
隠れてても たとえバレなくても悪いことはするなかれと
したら心のエネルギーの波動が狂っちゃうんです
ですから人類が自分に正直に生きていなさいと
そういう自分に正直に生きるということを出てきたら
どこでもどんなところでも生きていられるんですよ
たとえ銀行の金庫は一人に任せておいたっても
大丈夫なの その人はちょっとポケットに入れて持っていくということをしない
なぜなら自分に正直じゃないんだから
それは 今の社会は監視
監視 監視 監視と私の仕事は他の人を監視する
その人のもう一人の人は監視する
その人の仕事をまたもう一人の人が監視すると
それでもあちこちでお金が逃げたり
もう悪いことをしたり
法律を犯したりする 法律を守る警察さえ法律を犯したりする
人を脅したりする ブラックメールって何でしたっけ？脅迫したりする
それはやっぱり普通の世界では
それは別に警察はダメやということじゃない
人間だからそうなっちゃうんです
だからいい警察だからではなくて
人間で 私は自分の心に正直に生きていきますとという生き方だったら
もう今の社会の問題っていうのは解決するんです
そこで現代社会の生き方って言えば
この怒りに怒りで応える
一対一なんですね 悪いことをしちゃったら
その人を責めると 欲に欲で応える
だから目には目という生き方なんですね
で そこで問題解決したんですか？今までずっと人類が目には目という論理で生きてきたでしょうに
人を殺したらその人を殺してしまいます
じゃあそれで殺人のことは消えちゃったんですかと
それは消えません それは一応法律的に必要なものなんですけど
でも我々生きている人間はそうじゃなくて
逆の論理を作ってくださいと
怒りで燃えている人に親切さを教えてあげましょうと
欲でケチで燃えてる人に
もう物を分けて生活することを教えましょうと
いわゆる悪い心のエネルギーに同じ悪いエネルギーを出すんじゃなくて
毒は毒で解決するんではなくて
毒は解毒剤で解くもんなんですよ
で 仏教というのはそういう道なんですね
たとえあなたが私を殴っても
私は殴り返しませんと
それなんてあなたは弱いんだから
いえ 弱いんじゃなくて
そうすると私は汚れますと
あなたは殴ったら あなたに殴られて怪我するんだけど
その上私も人を殴って心は汚したくないんだと
という生き方なんです
そうすると そういう社会が出てきたら
もしかすると出てくるわけじゃないんだけど
もう社会の問題っていうのはなくしますよ
仏教で言ってる経済状態も同じく
人を幸福にことごとく全ての生命は幸福になるシステムが正しい経済であると
人のものを奪って自分だけ儲かることは経済ではないと
私は品物を作る 作る品物を売る
買った側は大変助かると
そうすると買った側助かるんだから
買った側も幸福になる
売った側もそれで儲かってるんだから幸福になる
現代でいうのあるのは
あるところで品物を作って売っちゃうと
それは買うでしょ 買った人はそれでお金がなくなって損する
それでもう二度と買えなくなっちゃうし
それで経済システムはピタッと止まってしまっちゃう
その経済の流れが止まる経験は思い存分味わってるんじゃないんですかね
でも見ようとしない 例えば今年は車はいっぱい売れたんですよと
これぐらい車が上がったんですよと威張るだけで
で 来年はまたドーンと下がったんですよとか
それ原因は探さない それでうまく流れません
車が売ったならば 買った側もそれで儲かって大変助かってるならば
もう次にもまた売れると
それは安全した経済のサイクルですか
循環なんですね まあそれ世の中どこにもないんだけど
釈迦様はそういう方法のことをおっしゃってるんですね
一応 8時まで 8時半まで
で またいろいろテーマありますけど
なかなか一つ絞らないと
そこで今度また現代社会
ちょっとした現象があるんです
現代 この宗教に興味ある人々がよく言われるこの聖飢魔II
聖飢魔IIということが出てくるんですね
全然わからない 何が聖飢魔IIかと
脅すというよりも 僕も何回も脅されていたんだけど
僕はかえって脅しちゃったんです
ある人を挙げて もう今いろいろ現象がありますよと
神様ももう人類はもう破滅する日にちはもう近寄っているんだよと
そしたらみんな破壊するんだと
ですから私はものすごく馬鹿馬鹿な顔をして
だからどうすればいいんですか？と言ったら
ああそうですねとすごく威張って
もうもう本を開けて まあこういうこういうことですから
この特別な自分の宗教をちゃんと信仰しなきゃもう救えませんと言ったら
あれ あんた方の宗教団体は地球でどれぐらいいるんですか？と聞いたんです
この地球であんた方の宗教を信じている人はどれぐらいいるんですかと
そしたらあまりはっきりした答え分からなかったんだけど
答え来なかったんで まあでももうどう見たっても
他の宗教を信じる人と信じない人々と
あなた方の宗教グループを信じる人と比べると
もう 1万分の 1 にもならないでしょうと
ほんのわずかでしょうと
まあそれはそうですと
ということは 世紀末になってみんな人類破滅したところで
あんた方だけ残るんだと
あんた方の親戚もみんな同じ宗教じゃないでしょ
あなた方の親戚も親も子供もみんな同じ宗教じゃないですから
あなた方の親戚も死んじゃって
あんた方残って面白いと思いますかと
僕はもうみんなと一緒に死にますから
どうぞ帰ってください
だからまあ偉そうに伝道しようと来るんだけど
こういう論理にもう答えられないんですよ
まあもう頭が悪いいんだから
そんなことをやって うちで掃除でもすればいいのに
こっちのはもう奥さんたちなんですけどね
で よくもそういうことを言うし
で 世紀末だ世紀末だからといってね
そんなとんでもない誤解だから
日本もどれほど損したんですかというと
そんな真に受けて こんなバカな話をね
世紀末だから宗教しなさいと
馬鹿げた話なんですよ
心を清らかにするのは世紀末じゃからじゃなくて人間だからでしょうに
たとえ世紀末であろうともなかろうとも
そんなことを関係なく
我々は優しい心を持って平和で常に生きているべきでしょうに
現代宗教に興味ある人々の一部がこの世紀末論をもうまとめに信じている
それ何回もこれもうひどい目に遭ったんだけど
その人々がそれでも信じていると
世紀末っていうのは昔のキリスト教ではね
もう計算してあったんで
この日にちで世界は終わりだと
その人は遠い昔とんだったんですよ
全然世界は変わらなかったんです
そこであれは計算間違いですよと
冗談じゃないでしょうに
だからその方々ももうちょっとおかしいんで
そうじゃなくて 世紀末あろうかなかろうが
心優しく人類に優しく
我々は短い人生だから生きていきましょうと言わなくちゃいけないところ
神様が最初の審判に来るんだから
早く頑張れと言うんですね
そこからの屁理屈なんですよ
もし最初の審判に来なかったら
遊び回ってもということでしょうに
だからお釈迦様はそうじゃないんですよ
我々の人生は短いんだから
その短い人生でなんで戦うんですか？何で敵を作るんですか？何で早死にするんですかね？戦争なんかに行って
断ればいいでしょうに
みんな戦争には入りま
軍隊に入りませんと 勝手にしろと
自分の人生だから私は仲良くするんだと
ですから 平和は今の時代は何のことなく実現しようとすればできますよ
誰もしようとしない 宗教はいつでも宗教的というのは宗教を信仰することではなくて
清らかな心で生きることは人間にどんな時代でもいつでも必要なことなんです
だから くだらない世紀末論なんかは何の意味もないんです
それは科学的なことで
人類は破滅するかしないかというのは科学的に計算するとわかるもんなんですよ
例えば空気を汚染するんだと
このスケールで汚染しちゃうと
あとはこの年で この何年経ったら終わりですよと計算上わかるでしょうに
そうするとみんな早く手を打って
もう何とか今でも頑張ろうと頑張っちゃうでしょうね
自然破壊しちゃったら
もうあまり長生きできませんよとわかったら早く手を打って何とかするでしょうね
そうするとどんどん世紀末は延びちゃうんですよ
神様は大変なんで 人間がいろんなことをやってるんだから
最後の審判がなかなかできない
あるいは人間がお互いに戦争するようになっちゃったら
もう原子爆弾あーだこうだ使っちゃって
もう人類は破滅する恐れがありますよ
あるいは宇宙から何かね
もう何か なんて言いますか
この落ちるもの 何て言いますか
たまに落ちるでしょ 隕石
何か巨大な隕石でも地球にぶつかるようになっちゃったら
みんな死ぬかもしれません
それだったら これ年 年
年か年前に知ってますからね
ちゃんと科学は発展しているんだから
それちゃんと見えるし
計算できるし 軌道はわかるし
地球には過去いろいろ隕石ぶつかったりして
みんな死んだ経験がありましたけどね
今見たら 最近そんなことはなかなかないし
そこで後で年 年 年経ったところで
そういう隕石が出てくるようになったって
そこでこちらから何か爆発物でも連れて行って
それそこで爆破して守ることもできるし
ですから もう人類破滅というのはいくらでも方法でも解決できますよ
それだったら宗教いらんことになっちゃうんですね
そこじゃなくて 人間である限り生きてるのは人間個人個人が短いんだから
そこを美しく光り輝いて
幸福で清らかな心で生きていなくちゃいけない
元気で そこは別にもう選択の余地がない話なんです
だから私には世紀末には絶対もう無視してください
そんなことも 単なる年
年になることに驚いているだけなのに
もうただの数字変わるだけで
年が年になるだけのことで
よくもこの嘘に操られるということは情けないんですよ
現代人として ノストラダムスがああ言ったこう言ったとか
本当は一つも当たってないんです
強引に解釈してるだけで
ちょっと明確に見て読んでみてください
一つも当たってないんです
そこで超能力持ってる人がいるんじゃないかとか
じゃあ超能力持ってるんだったら何かやってくれと
何もやってくれてないんだから
それより科学の方にはすごい超能力あるんだから
誰か誰かさんが何か水を飲ませたところで病気治しましたよとか
それだったら片っ端から病気の人々に 一度でいいんだから
一度でいいんだから その人の水を飲ませて病気治してくれたら信じますよ
ただ何人かしか治してない
それも僕から見れば怪しいと
物質化する現象を誰かが持ってるんだと言ってるし
宇宙からもう何かいろんな宝石作ったり
指輪作ったり ネックレス作ったりするんだと
それ何で宝石ネックレスみたいに指輪みたいにほんのちっちゃなものを作るんですかね
宇宙空間から何でも物質化できるんだったら
巨大な建物ぐらい その聖者たちがね
例えば東京都庁ですか
それぐらい建物をその国でいきなり作ってくれたら
誰でも僕でも信じますよ
なんでそれできないんですかね
そんなに物質 物質化現象ですか
それはそこまでできるならば
そんなものは本当であろうか
嘘であろうが関係ないんだけど
人類の役に立たないことだけは確かなんですね
もしかするその人は本当にそういう能力を持ってるかもしれません
でも生成できるのは指輪一つ作るぐらいで
日本製の時計一つ作ってくれるぐらいで
時計は人為的に作りますけど
それは日本製なんですね
もしそれは本当の能力であっても
私は僕はけなしたくないんです
本当にそういう能力あったにしても
人類には役に立たないんですよ
ただ 我々を脅してほしければ
私が言うのは東京の都庁ぐらいでも建物一つボーンと作ってくださいと
瞬時に それだったら信じてあげますと
そうでない限りはインチキやと
私個人的にはね [笑い]と言いたいところなんですけど
ですから お釈迦様が言うのは
清らかな心でみんなと仲良くして平和で生きることは
過去現在未来いつでも必要なものだよと
悪いことをしたら悪い結果はいつでも起こりますよと
いい行動をするといい結果になることはいつでもあることだよ
それは永遠の真理だよと
お釈迦様は一切いつでもこういうエサダンモサナントノという言葉言ってるんです
これは法のみち あるお経
偈文があって この最後にこの言葉出てくる
エサダンモサナントノ
この何かおっしゃったから
これはサナントノ 永遠というか普遍的な教えですよと
いつでも通用する教えだよと
サナントノというのはフォーエバーという意味で
だから釈迦様おっしゃった教えが過去でも通用しますし
現在でも通用するし 将来でも通用するし
問題は我々はこれは聞くか実践するかということであって
問題は私たちにあってブッダにはないんです
一応ブッダは一人の人間でしたから
真理をおっしゃってもう亡くなって消えていった
その教えは未だにあることはある
もう実行すればすぐそこで幸福な社会と幸福な人間
幸福な心 清らかな心は確実に生まれるんだと
法則は法則だから真理だから
これはもう時代と関係ないと
そういうわけで 仏教は思い存分十分現代社会にも未来社会にも通用する教えだよという結論で話を終了させていただきます
どうも五年 五回分けて付き合っていただいて
どうもありがとうございました